tu as fait une magnifique fête pour
annoncer à tout le monde voilà tu vas
faire certainement peut-être une
magnifique fête encore aussi pour
naissance du bébé et a fait aussi une
magnifique tête mort à 9,7 au monde le
sexe de son futur bébé
c'est ce qu'on appelle une baby shower
eh bien nous ce soir on va faire ce
qu'on appelle une mamie chômage et pour
qui je suis isabelle dans une cabine de
douche on va cette rageante y aller mais
que gentil battu accompagner on peut
mettre on reste à côtés d'isabelle et
angola où l'animal pour de vrais nobel
s'est fait un enfoncement thoracique
mais non mais non voyons comment je sais
non mais t'inquiètes pas j'ai la belle
va sur quatre dont une cabine de douche
je me dis merde je vais poser il ya un
petit siège en plus un pourri pour la
baignoire
matt fêter les questions sur les bébés
alors si tu est fin prêt à devenir papa
tu réponds bien tout va bien si tu te
trompes la douche se mettra en route
alors de l'eau coulera sur isabelle
c'est qu'elle déteste ça c'est ça ben
alaoui ses cheveux là elle a deux fois
les poitrines et l'eau les mamies non
mais je suis inquiète et ça c'est rien
mais ouais c'était toujours de pluie de
l'eau de la base les cas les notions
comme les douchettes elle son crescendo
ça veut dire ça sera de plus en plus
alors attention première question selon
les pédiatres
quelle est la température maximum pour
le bain d'un nouveau né alors c'est sûr
maximum pour le bain d'un nouveau né ou
le bada 30
pas loin de la température du corps je
dirais 30 alors 38 zanon louvoie entre
35 et 38 degrés celsius à ma bonne
réponse de match
la mamie mais moi j'ai 14 ans fonctionne
mais même pas lorsqu'un bébé pleure il
est capable de faire autant de bruit que
un aspirateur un marteau piqueur ou une
scie circulaire
sachez qu'on a un il ya quelqu'un qui a
calculé les décibels un aspirateur
sachez qu'un bel ancien club violents
comme un bébé qui pleure il peut
atteindre 110 décibels non un aspirateur
ne fait que 75 et un marteau piqueur 120
décibels c'est une scie circulaire une à
une petite mamie choisir une petite
mamie show rien c'est rien c'est rien ça
sert à ça de ma mère attention question
à 5 centimètres près entre sa naissance
son premier anniversaire
de combien de centimètres en moyenne un
bébé grandit t-il à 5 cm est allé à 300
tués c'est grandir et on en vint way 25
25 65 centimes ces 23 cm bonne voie
non rien ce que quand ça rend pas tu te
plains les cancers
attention selon l'institut national des
études statistiques durant quelles mois
de l'année observe-t-on le plus de
naissances dans le monde à quel mois de
l'année ouais je dirais bien vu qu'on
fait des souvent des bébés en été je
dirais en mars avril par la maaf sabri
alors depuis quelques années le boom de
naissance juin a lieu en septembre avec
un pic le 23 septembre
nous venons en à ce qu'on fait bah oui
on sait pas se couper un baby shower to
play offs et qui ne prend qu il n'y a
que vous avez choisi pour visée parce
que
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
sur 100 français combien n'assiste pas à
la naissance de l'europe et tout pour
tout caler tout calinous c'est quand il
y en a deux enfants seraient nés sont
fermés
mignon mignon petit bout tout cas je
dirais qu'ils n'assistent pas c'est à
dire qu'ils sont pas dans la liesse oui
je ne sont pas dans la plaie évidemment
ça va on y va pas bien son nom car on
n'est pas au juste prix là je vais pas
dire que je vais aller de l'autre côté
avec l quoi la comm réd aujourd'hui la
digérer 21 cents soit pour 125 25 avril
à qui il a dit jeudi 25 à tomber c'est
alors isabelle ya deux solutions ou vous
dites je suis m pokora à 20% à combien
de % près d'ailleurs
[Rires]
il est soit du pays si vous voulez pas
faire hop tous les foyers français
combien n'assiste pas à la naissance de
leur enfant
il a 10 % est ce que vous me suivez où
est la magie 55%
vous êtes sûre et certaine
ah non mais j'ai ce que je dis ça mais
vous préférez lui préfère la tienne ou
la mienne cette ancienne 55
alors si la sienne est plus proche que
la mienne à l affaire to peer celles qui
s'occupent de laquelle on est la bonne
alors il est ce que tu es avec moi tu
vas dire la bonne réponse et avait dit
combien toi voilà 10 20 20 est là à
10,55 la bonne réponse et si mal
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des ratios
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]